I want to ask you a question about your
faith because we share the same Faith
but how do you know
that that is God calling you because
everywhere you go people love you how to
even Democrats love you because you're
just a nice wholesome good person who
does the right thing and uh and you're
honest you're honest but they might not
like your politics but they like who you
are in your character so I I love that
first of all everybody loves you
Democrats love you listen Democrats
don't love them and the Maga people
wanted them killed on January 6th so I
don't know what on Earth Ainsley Earhart
is talking about but I love the question
how do you know that that's God really
speaking to you it's sort of like one of
these things where Bush said he spoke to
God and God told him to invade Iraq and
then uh you know all these stories that
are told I I checked with God and God
said to go ahead and do it or God chose
this word was it maybe just indigestion
and God not really speaking to you